believe you know I watched it once did
tell Rick Levin that the elimination of
the education is great the best place in
the world to get an education in media
of the 19th century so I so I wanted I
want to go quick ee products but what I
wanted to do is try to capture some old
get wisdom for free and I hope you and
elicits of interactivity I've done a lot
of done some in college a lot of note
viewing products and my experience is
best of sessions people can take away
one and a half ideas and here's what it
means to take away an idea it means that
you can figure out how to take action on
it in the next week so one half ideas so
your goal is one and a half ideas from
this next bit of time and my experience
is the only people who ever take away
more than one I have ideas of people
that take notes or check the blog later
so if your ambition if you know if
you're a lifelong learner who likes to
get more than one and a half things for
45 minutes either take notes or sit next
to someone who is that kind of person um
this is some stuff I've done you know
it's kind of games and companies and
brands any questions you know I'm kind
of self-assembly have seen some you have
it but it's um you know that I did the
some of the early math and John Madden
football I use it to tell educators that
video games a great way to teach math
and you know other stuff so the
generalized you're managing yourself or
you're managing other people there you
can think about what your career bucket
list in games console video games take
about two years to build and now mobiums
take about a year or so if your Creator
if your business of doing one thing a
year and you've got 40 years of work
life ahead if you joined got 40 things
to do so if you start imagining it each
is one of 40 you might try the Lord and
for those of you have multiple a fewer
than 40 years to go you know each bicho
each try is a little more precious so my
day job at said I'm kind of a venture
capitalist now for six years we've been
in this thing called product works at
Kleiner Perkins on the chief product
officer what that means is i touch 15 of
our portfolio companies per month easy
in about a 90 minute product sessions
starting with an audit and for those of
you don't know what we consider product
management be used to be people
management and kind of it glue which by
the way young people a tad and now it's
very much a quant because all this tech
stuff is always connected to servers and
everything can be instrumented and
there's kind of a tendency for quants to
believe believe the data from the server
or more than they believe real people so
good thing about Yale is is they tend to
be very people-oriented the residential
college system gives lifelong benefits
that those in tech industries are just
starting to appreciate on seven boards
and keep investing so in the last three
and a half months co invested along with
an investing partner for companies duo
lingo and
is a leading language learning app
that's free that's business model is
selling translations of three cents a
word that are done by the advanced
students secret which is a anonymous
secret sharing mostly true and kind of
starting to break tech news like the
Google+ dude leave an advanced showed up
on secant ahead of TechCrunch better
works which is okay our objective and
key result creation cascading through
enterprise I'm a big believer in setting
goals than being transferring what they
are and mango health which is a
prescription medicine adherence app
created by a game guy okay so since
we're at Yale want to talk about how to
be educated in my experience I've not
met a single college president or high
school president who has a working
definition of educated you know that
mean educated as you got the degree that
I offer so you're credited here's my
definition of educated and and I think
definitions should tamp stand the test
of machine readability and why you know
because I'm an English major who things
like a geek so to be educated in college
or grad school or in life you have to
have completed three projects one big
family room by doing John Dewey was the
original educator and learn by doing i
actually think that's the joy of
technology-based manipulatives as you go
learn by doing a scalable way without
breaking the stuff i think understanding
data is really important and that is
it's not just numbered data it's you
know scientific data what is clean data
all scientists know
that capturing the data is really hard
and all sales people know that the
secret to sales is to ignore the
outliers you know make the case you want
and use the numbers to prove your case
and ignore the outliers and then
understand rhetoric most people in
business can't differentiate between
data and rhetoric so it's pretty
important you know rhetoric is it's not
the intrinsic the extrinsic aspects that
make something listenable a believable
it turns out rhyme and alliteration make
the same statement seems somewhere
between two and three times as
believable as measured by people I once
had a professor who said his lesson in
life is if you have a bad lecture wear a
suit so the suits the rhetoric get the
lecturers there and then there's a guy
named Franz Johansson at Stanford who
wrote a book called the Medici effect
and he asserts and thinks he can prove
that creativity happens in the
intersection of two domains it's where
the most valuable patents happen he also
asserts that the most valuable patents
are created by the people who create the
most palace so in general and creativity
I'm a fan of iteration and doing a lot
rather than waiting to do just one good
thing by the same thing is true of
entrepreneurship never entrepreneur
because you expect you because you're
planning on your first thing to succeed
on the preneur because you want to fail
for a long time and have fun at it or
not to preneur because you can't work
for a boss that's the whole that's
actually the only really legit reason
entrepreneur is that you are
unmanageable and you just and your
signal so expert in two domains it's a
little like language learning all
Europeans
that once they know two languages may
can be more more malleable in their
thinking you know they kind of imagined
for multiple points of view you know
Americans tend not to do that so think
Americans extra two domains is like
basketball and football okay i'm
building a toolkit in general you know
your job in your career and in life is
to constantly improve your toolkit your
portfolio is not just for art I actually
think resumes are their kind of a
Rorschach test if I think about yourself
but they're not very valuable they
mostly Unseld you rather than so
anything about what is your portfolio
it's stuff you're doing it work so we do
at school in school and in business
school and gradual your job is to create
three the three projects always have
three great portfolio things it comes up
call them my business planets on KBC be
calm so I think everything you do it's
worth having when English teachers would
call an outline until the middle bottle
of business plan it's four slides the
first slide is the movie poster that's
your vision which is someday if all goes
well customers like these are going to
be using my thing like these and
everything that's going to change the
world by the second is your five good
idea is the third is your five best
assets and the fourth is numbers that's
designed thinking for those who follow
David and Tom Kelly and I do design
thinking again is looking for Layton
needs with cameras and video cameras in
consumers to places of power not in your
office and and then iterating with
increasing in high resolution prototypes
and I think it's probably the most
important
creative manipulative there is by the
way in education I'm a strong fan of
winning by two manipulatives the way to
teach science and start with gardening
the way to teach drama and English is to
start with telling stories the way to
teach movies is to start with sitting
around a Jewish or Italian table and
trying to get your story and while
somebody else is talking and who at
school in hillsboro is a school that has
this kind of curriculum map with new
manipulatives entered all the way at the
ultimate in math it's graphic calculator
for middle schoolers yells not very good
at manipulating was so far for the
humanities manipulative is Microsoft
Word and search engine you basically
have to you know I'm not a fan of
textbooks and then writing and
presenting you know most kids at Yale
don't fear presenting because they kind
of trust that they have friends who want
dis too bad but facility to write
inquisitions report okay I'd like to
talk to people many of them were younger
than you about you know what I know now
what I advise my 21 year old self and in
general what I did real well is I did
kind of the liberal arts decade of the
20s there's a book called the defining
decade the the talk is not as good as
the book it's a quick read but I just
did stuff that's kind of you know it you
know liberal arts universities have this
bias to chop everything and don't get
the main specific too fast and you know
I
this because for a while I paid my bills
by being a commercial fisherman and you
know I was probably too stupid to know
but this is why 18 to 25 year olds fight
wars because they are fearless and
feeling vulnerable and then a pattern
achievement to me the most important
thing in any resume is that most of the
stuff that somebody tried there is a
pattern if not success of micro
achievement and my senses achievers all
keep metrics so I use the term fitness
function but you know if you care about
success you should know what the what
the fitness function or the medicine
sesa what I didn't do well and I was
basically a jerk to people in authority
it was probably a father issue but so I
have never had a superior officer of
Mentor i chafe under under taking orders
and in fact what I've discovered is all
people in their 20s waste a year and a
waste for lack of context and so what a
mentor can do is say don't move to
Florida or don't date that guy or don't
take that high-priced job that you don't
want and you know to some degree life is
like chess you know my mouth chess
player my sense of chess is one bad move
against a equal opponent cause the loss
and everything you do do i doing the one
the one bad move and then write down
plans so I'm a big fan of reflecting you
know psychologists would say that people
tend to look at the path
as if it was manifest destiny and
forgetting the other variability or the
infinite the infinite universes that are
possible at any point and we just kind
of anchor on the past as Manifest
Destiny you would be shocked if you go
back and read your own plans that in
retrospect seem really smart I did go
back and read some of the early
marketing and product plans and
Electronic Arts and it's so sophomore I
mean thank goodness you know kids at
Yale today aren't on a sophomoric as I
was back then as we were creating kind
of one of the great brands interactive
entertainment but but write it down make
projection predictions in fact I think
if somebody wants entrepreneur you
should write a business plan every month
keep it in a folder and review Steven
Spielberg says ideas are gifts from the
gods when he has an idea it's self
discipline is to write one page of a
movie script before he goes to bed that
night about that idea you can too it's
really hard you know its own it's like
writing a diary daily if you have a
boring life and saving stuff it used to
be really hard but you know use your own
user on data of the past to look into
the future writers do this writers I
once aspired to be a writer and then I
met somebody who said thing you don't
understand writers write and you know
you don't be a writer by thinking about
it you write for 40 or 50 hours a week
no matter what and I would say the same
thing entrepreneurs entrepreneur it's
just if you're good entrepreneur you
don't sit around and wait they have that
great idea you do stuff ok the next
thing is everybody comes out at yell
community
is a number one graphic you know it's
like being tailback at USC you are you
know everybody in the L community is
tailback us see the rimae uses a
metaphor SP were sports fans they know
that general managers and coaches get
fired if they mismanaged in the road
graphics also get fired if they pick the
wrong ones but it's really hard to prove
that you pick the wrong one it's easier
to prove the amiss managed and here's
what you do quarterbacks and hockey
defenceman get made backups and they get
some training defensive linemen and
running backs are starters the first
year and so you ought to have an order
out the plan for yourself it turns out
in the years nineteen sixty to ninety 90
in the NBA the NFL sixty-five percent of
number-one draft picks not the whole
round which is the single in one
sixty-five percent made all pro at least
one year and because if you're the
number one draft pick of the first round
you'd expect that thirty percent the
Hall of Fame so you know if you have
that says okay if you're if you're a
Yalie you should be an all-pro in
business and all pro is a CEO or vp of a
meaningful company or somebody who's
really rich by shuffling papers on Wall
Street and you know hall of fame is its
not all the way to man of the year on
Time magazine but you know there's yeah
I know Adam actually know what Hall of
Fame into business then I got a couple
other rules on number one draft pick the
rule is seven I found especially with
kids ask how productive for you today
and here's the metric attend is the most
productive you've been in life and
that's a but you want to party their
friends go back to your room you wrote a
30 page paper and you studied for two
exams the Esen both the next day that's
a ten a one
you're sitting in fifth grade and some
boring lectures and evaluate some boring
lecture you're watching the clock kind
of move really slowly like therapy oh
that's one and then ask people where are
you today and I found people can tell
and seven is the perfect number if
you're a cycling fan seven is you're in
the peloton and you're doing 2,000 k of
20 days again is an attack going uphill
you just can't do tens very often and I
by most people their 20s when they think
they're doing a 10 they're breaking
things and causing problems for others
that just kind of all put it about so 10
is possible but 10 is 40 tak so you know
Savior 7 is repeatable you still there
seven every day so hopefully today if
you answer so house today for me is
today a seven you know you still have
time to make it a seven and it's not
already but probably somebody here that
if you met for the first time they could
turn today to hide a tree and then the
rule of thirty percent is a little bit
weird bear with me think Cartesian
coordinates think of slope and then on
the horizontal axis is years and the
vertical access is career progress most
people have a thought about over time
when we get to vote here you know
Stanford MBA is all think in 10 years
i'm going to be a CEO / to me is all
thinking two years i'm going to be a CEO
guess the heart goes through the AV
and my experience is if you're a manager
you should know the career slope
aspirations for every one of your
employees and if you're an employee use
make sure your manager know you becomes
yours and you can ask am I on track it'd
be such and such in two years and in my
sense is is usually a gap we'd like
people to believe that are better than
their bosses think they are but the gap
should never be more than thirty percent
so if you think two years and they think
more than three years this time so going
for a job if you start looking for a job
you know in all entrepreneurship
including yourself you need to circle a
day in the calendar and say if I don't
reach this milestone but by this date
I'm going to shut it down and do
something else my sense is a vp needs to
give the company a year a director about
six months everybody else in the world
of three months there any chance we can
get a light here need rami do I on by
the way that's Wayne Gretzky you look at
him and you go I know he's going to be
the best hockey player of all time and
he's going to marry some beautiful
actress and then he's going to he's
going to win the Olympics and wind
cannabis on her back you look at him and
go no
okay how to pick your first job is
pregnant that meaningful they give you
any more but if you're paying forward
people which many Yale people are others
are going to ask you you probably know
my school kids and eight-year-olds so
here's my advice when in doubt take an
industry that has more jobs than people
and the reason is people are treated
like valuable commodities they're nicer
to each other you know if you're going
to show biz it's going into show biz a
little like trying to major in pre-med
or economics you know in college those
departments try to convince people in
the first class don't major in my major
there's too many of us and it's not that
great anyway one the next thing the Yale
experience shopping a professor shop a
boss think one bit of advice I heard
from jeff frenzel edina Gayle is don't
take classes for content take it for the
prof by the way I think the same thing
about going on African safaris the
country yoga doesn't matter the guide is
everything and then you can look to see
if it's a meritocracy system system or
seniority system in general the key the
number one signal is a meritocracy as
there's somebody under 25 in the
executive suite in general I think I've
found that 35 year olds are the enemy of
innovation just just think of 35 you got
house payments you probably are starting
to have kids you've worked hard to get
where you are the last thing you want to
do is
threw it up and but if you're if you're
the boss of a 35 year olds you want
everybody to maximize their expected
value you can play a portfolio but to
play a portfolio 35 year olds you got to
have each of them maximize expected
outcome not minimize possibility failure
I can explain it in more math if you'd
like but when the other to go out and
then finally record do is produce
profile and that is not a resume but
what do you good at what do you like to
do all day what would your friends say
about you and then match that of a
friend who ran sales than the sims
electronic guards and she said she had
an eighth grade teacher in 8th grade
said what do you like to do all that and
young Nancy wrote that I'd like to be a
people like to travel I like everyday to
be different than the next and as she
was backing up to moved from Laguna
Beach to Chicago to be a court reporter
and you know those are the people that
just sit and type can't talk all day and
have to be invisible and this thing fell
out of her hope chest and she looked at
it in her heart sank that I've lost
myself and a year later she was moved to
a sales career and became a Hall of
Famer so having to his profile early and
you know staple it to the refrigerator
I'm a big fan of a lifelong learning in
general to be a life the first signaling
or not a lifelong learner as you take
feedback with your arms crossed and you
know this is a normal body posture for
women I think it's comfortable probably
more comfortable than men but you know
force yourself when you when you're
getting notes to open up and don't don't
say don't say no and then I'm elicits a
little longer than this but I tell
people who wonder should I get an MBA
there's 13 reasons to get an MBA the
first reason is you're in a career where
MBA is required and that's Asian top
industries consulting and it used to be
banking but anymore it's not so there
are not very many businesses where an
MBA actually is required to step ahead
and the opportunity cost of getting an
MBA is about 250 grand so it's pretty
expensive so this the second reason to
get an MBA which was my reason is it's a
get-out-of-jail card you're stuck in an
industry you need to whitewash your
personal position I was an unemployable
commercial fisherman and and you know i
came i went to Stanford and I was still
kind of a semi unemployable commercial
fisherman but at least I got interviews
and the third reason is it's a it's a
really great vacation and you can afford
it it's an MBA business school it was
not as intellectually demanding as as a
Yale undergraduate unless you're on a
PhD job and anybody who hasn't done it a
bread stone wrote the everything store
I'd advised him to write each chapter
starting with a shareholder letter
instead he made up a fiction that the
initiative is an Amazon we're all
predetermined and were separable but
Bezos basis is up there with a Warren
Buffett in his letters Warren Buffett's
the other writer I'm a fan of trying to
see how people fast track from at 18 to
30 so there's a concept and Hollywood
called elements and an element is
someone who in attached
project makes the project bankable it
can be a writer that can be a director
it can be a movie star it's very rarely
something that can be a book property so
you know your view job is to become an
element as soon as possible so I'm going
out and I found all the people at
Electronic Arts who were elements by age
29 and then I went to the people who
voted them along the way and asked why
and surprisingly enough the people who
have influence on your career not a very
crisp thinking and here's what i came
down to they would say everything I
asked him to do they completed that's
like that's like you know it's like I'm
all girls in school they did all their
homework and they did it well in some
boys but the net the next thing is I
don't know they just always ask the best
questions they always got me thinking
and everybody from Yale should be able
to ask the best questions in the room
not in a smarmy way of the best
questions in the room and then finally
they're always brimming with new ideas
you know the way that the way that
people get bet on is where we got a
problem I need somebody this well Jake's
got good ideas maybe I can get him to do
something he doesn't go often start a
company and be worthless to my company
then there's this notion of a career
chasm and in general high potential
young people are incompetent in groups
you know you think about it no young
people are trained in groups bigger than
about three you know universities
organized around study carrels if you're
a player coach you could be a you know a
lot of the activities you get the
there's a lot of opportunities for
leaders in junior year but but you know
most people are better off being a guild
manager in world of warcraft then going
to college and they want to leave and
then the next thing that happens is when
you get a job you are hazed in a career
as you are hazed in a society hill and
and your boss is usually a bad boss the
first second boss and they want you to
focus on television on task and then
it's some wedding a wow this person is
going to be promoted and then your
expect to go from task the big picture
and it's almost impossible unless you've
been looking a big picture along the way
so it's actually one of the best things
about a liberal arts degree if you take
advantage of it is you've got a lot of
comparing to trust you have what theatre
11 calls and marketing imagination from
task ownership again is from do this
right now it's kind of blue-collar
aspects of white-collar to take an area
responsibility and do what you're told
to excite and motivate other people my
experience is it's really hard to
predict as an employer who's going to
cross this chasm and one prediction of
being a leader is there's always people
hanging out around their desk of another
is kind of in their personal life
they're always leading and stuff it's
really hard and I you know I'm probably
wrong thirty percent of the time
learning managing is also really hard
and you think about managing best
metaphor is sports coach you know a
sports coat the job is to get to three
more wins per season out of this
group of players and you know I could
talk to sports coaches how they do it
it's a little bit of strategy it's a lot
of motivation when I found in getting
interested in sports analytics coaches
don't care about analytics general
managers care about I want a coach's
care about motivation and they fine tune
their motivation to every single player
so back to the thirty percent if you
know that this player wants to be all
pro and will work harder than Jerry Rice
you know you want to you want to build
that you know this guy's just trying to
make money and doesn't care even with
the team wins you gotta do something
else my experience is people who are not
natural managers the the best approach
is to try to be a great teacher I think
teaching can be learned managing there's
no great ways to learn how to be a
manager except for being a parent the in
this thing about the job and parenting
is most people are amateurs they don't
do it very often you'd never go to a
doctor to get heart surgery with someone
is inexperienced as we all are as
parents will become parents it's a it's
extremely humbling especially if your
kids are in a family with more jobs than
people and then finally I've been lying
for people with high aspirations it's
always useful in any problem situation
is if you're the person that you want it
to be how would you perform right here
so hopefully you've all had at least one
awful boss and if you've written down if
this person would only be like this
happy better and then don't be that
awful boss and I believe in their
activities a way to check the not the
awful boss is to start a conversation we
work with Mir awesome lots in my arm I
you're awful boss I just saw had an alex
gardner showed up at zynga this week as
president of studio
goes and he sat down with a 50 liters
and said I work for you here's my cell
phone number it's going to be available
to every employee in the company and
Microsoft other 20,000 people had my my
phone my cell phone number and my SLA on
email responses 24 hours and if I don't
achieve that holy to it what do you
think would happen if at universities
the SLA on homework assignment grading
and responses 24 hours people would play
less reward okay CEO 2 point 0 I assert
that the job of CEO is changing due to
the job in sports you know Vince
Lombardi used to be an authority figure
for servicing coaches in their 30s who
are more peers so what I'm noticing
people every time they become a CEO they
raise their hiring standards so your job
as a CEO is to get to your perfect team
as fast as possible the president nited
states the best example the day their
inaugural a have this slate of their
perfect team all all dominated my
experiences first time CEOs tend to take
two plus years to get the perfect team
together second time about 1 year and
third time CEOs um break rules to get
get the perfect team assemble in three
months I'll beat the clock and since all
great teams that I've been experienced
with your goal is to calendar weeks of
work every week if you're in the Moore's
law business you have to beat the clock
so agility modularity and great people
house teams that are doing one week of
progress / / to calendar weeks all die
if somebody is saying yeah we're not
going to ship until it's time they're
still doing stuff in trouble be the
customer you would be shocked at two
things one is most people most
first-time entrepreneurs tend to stop
doing the thing
got up there so if you get promoted in a
bigger role don't stop them what you
used to do you can and then me the
customer you'd be shocked at how many
missionary companies how many people are
a missionary companies who don't have a
single friend that they've convinced to
use the product and did they stay in
touch with so you can actually count you
know if you don't have ninety percent of
your employees being missionary to at
least one customer oh you're not doing
your job and then finally you know I'm a
friend in marketing assistant is the
only valuable thing in marketing I think
in business leadership culture is the
most valuable thing and it's just
shocking how soon you can go back and
then as if you are ever presenting to
investors you should know what you walk
out of the room they never say wow what
a business plan it's always do you like
her or not did she blow you away is she
great because great entrepreneurs always
find a way to return and business plans
rarely do next is does this leader have
scalable skills so they have a vision
that when they have to talk to 100
people will work do they understand the
tech stack so this thing bigger and
bigger and then finally just as with a
college application all the pieces the
application have to tell one story I do
the numbers tell the same story as a
baby and then and you know it's great to
see you know this is the beach yet so
yell people are the best synthesizers
and team builders of any selective
University probably in the world see it
again and again and again yay lilly's
are not very good at being [ __ ] you
know that's why there's there's more
entrepreneurs
you know it's on Harvard does a really
good job of making their undergraduates
you know uncomfortable I mean it's an
awful experience the teachers can't
really they have so many classes the
hatred and then what Yale is don't do so
well is gift from books to pragmatism
and from Lawrence two numbers and Comp
Sci so you know you're a brand Jake
Tyler there's ways to be an adult
learner of counts i and you know a way
to be pragmatic is to try stuff with
people who went to Community College
it's interesting to see Rick Lebanon
corsair announced elevate leading heart
and innovation yo gets it that new
heaven it just can't be the new oxygen
and then a network you know it's a pan
horizontally but also they all must be
kind to the next generation coming
behind us and let's work a little harder
to give them give them a beachhead and
oh and you know a few of publishing
stuff on KPCC com we've got councils of
80 design leads and product leads and
companies that get together half
portfolio half oh that's kind of cool I
tweet a little bit and that's my email
and I answer email but not decide 24
hours unless your student and this is
the first k PCB design fella group and
there's a couple Yale agreement which
may be really proud
minimum viable free zone is anybody
delighted to ask a question or get a
clarification to make a common do it in
the white shirt eyes answer question
people white shirts because they're
gonna run investment bank something so
its data versus people I think more
broadly its data versus design but I
actually think that if you're a fan of
behavioral psychology you know
psychology is moving from Freud the
numbers and eraser in Freud to Skinner
and I think for any of you who haven't
like that look at okcupid it's a dating
site that publishes their analytics all
the funnel and retention data and
attraction data on okcupid looks a lot
like any kind of mobile I so you know
media seeing a customer getting here in
landing page you're a page for the first
time it's a lot like walking into a
restaurant for a blind date you know if
you lose the first five seconds of
history so to me the issue about design
versus plumbed the designers can imagine
what the test and then can do design
rhetoric to make stuff Morrison now if
you know that it's possible for a label
to increase sales and touch ability by
fifty percent it probably not more than
fifty percent although I did see on on
old style beer 3x on an offshoot of the
air pan incident chains again no
advertising free
sales so if you know that now you go to
designer and say okay try like crazy the
possibilities for us and then you've got
to test long way I think designers tend
to imagine what to test and then quants
can measure the test the negative of
quants is numbers people tend to
overvalue a short-term approval and
undervalued long-term and it's it's easy
to figure out why that if you run a test
that takes you know a year oh you don't
get the claim results for a year and so
you're uneasy for a long time so this
DNA inch product management makes the
mistake the kind of local maximum
mistake over value and stuff these
provable a dollar a day and so I think I
do both I try to keep the quant stream
gone and intuition stream of the people
strands that I think in your lifetime
and you're going to see that most
interpersonal behaviors are going to be
quantifiable the signs you know we're
going to do it with heart rate monitors
and lie detectors and skin galvanometers
and you have brain scans yes
Houston technology change organizational
design I think organizational design
architecture should match the
architecture of computer programs
there's a stack and it's also modularity
and the modular design the hardest job
is the architect own so CEO is an
architect so if you want to give meaning
to people you want them to be to be
close to two outcomes and see building a
modules Jeff Bezos calls them to pizza
teams but it turns out it's really hard
when you when you do modular code and
the reason most code architectures don't
become modular to the second generation
it's really hard to predefined the IO
basil says has two bits of teams that
that everybody of the team's calendar
should be ninety percent of their hours
should be just 19 more than 10
percentile because as computer
scientists now IO is the killer or
performance so the problem isn't meeting
is the problem is too much time in Iowa
okay the question is reflection regret
happening for a reason though I would
say first about reflection I mean I
think regret is just a signal that you
should pay attention to reflecting on
that and then it can be if it can be
dehumanizing you know it's really clear
that the confidence makes people better
make some more creative it makes some
more valuable people around them so in
general yell people you know use your
interview lets you know you've got to
enter every room with a smart and not in
your room with I'm smarter than you
which comes from other schools and then
though it's really hard to to find
useful data and I think regret is a
signal then there's the data they're
saying somebody else a most people who
are successful misunderstand what got
him there if you read the book built the
last they'd say is what he thought Colin
says is what he is nearly he could tell
the actual value system that a company
has has no signaling effect for success
the commitment to the value system and
the alignment of the value system is
highly correlated with success so most
people is why I'm successful are wrong
you know in fact four guys in business
the number one reason to be successful
for success is your height and you know
the immigrant anybody say you know John
Donne moiety they say you know my
success of my honey you might you know
you might have heard you ain't even here
Shaq's ax and my success my ability to
dance and but it's kind of it's it's an
unfair advantage
life energy is on very well you know you
do it the old-fashioned way by be a
better than people around you know it
did I mean a short is great for
motivation especially for men you know
the Holy but you know something that is
when successful I would be skeptical the
most people don't know you know ask your
loved ones why why am I so good I
recently asked my daughter somebody
asked what's your secret to parenting
rights if we were home from dinner every
night we did this and focus on education
and one daughter sketch she kind of
button that and the other daughter was a
little bit older and wiser said no I
might just like this and i would never
thought I'd million years and you know
so she came up support we're going to
wrap because the guy holding the number
thing is I mean such a stink place you
can't believe
well let's go